So, we've done a lot of work with cake. And, as much as I like cake, especially
chocolate cake, let's see how else we can use our fractions. Even if I spend all
that time baking, I probably want to go outside. So, let's see our fractions in
another content. Walking.
So here's our next problem with fractions. You walk two fifths of a kilometer
and then three tenths of a kilometer. How far did you walk? When thinking about
this problem, I know I need to do something with these fractions. I'm trying to
figure out the total distance I have to walk. So I should probably. Add these
fractions together. So I have two fifth added to three tenths. Here I don't have
common denominators, I cannot just add these together. So let's see what we can
do. But you might be wondering what's a kilometer. A kilometer is a measure of
distance. We use the letter km to stand for kilometer. There's also the word
kilo. Kilo means a thousand. So we know one kilometer is really a thousand
meters. And you're probably wondering what's that distance like? So here's a
picture of about a kilometer. In New York City, Central Park is about 849 meters
across. 849 meters is just shy of 1,000 meters. So we know Central Park is.
About a kilometer, but a little bit less then that. If you wanted to see for
yourself how long a kilometer is you could go outside, it takes about twelve
minutes to walk a kilometer depending on how fast you walk. Alright, now that we
know what a kilometer is let's get back to problem solving. Okay, I've rewritten
our problem at the top, we walk two fifths of and then walked three tenths of a
kilometer. How far did you walk? Let's picture this using a kilometer. I'm going
to draw a bar that represents a kilometer. So this distance, or the full bar,
would be one kilometer. Two fifths of a kilometer would only be this much. Let's
say the same thing for three tenths. Let's split up our kilometer bar into
tenths. So I have a full kilometer bar, I have tenths, And three of them are
shaded to repr esent three tenths of a kilometer. If I wanted to ever add two
fifths and three tenths together, it would look like this. I would have the two
fifths and then the three tenths Don't fall into the trap of thinking this is
five out of fifthteen. I don't have fifthteen equally divided regions here. Even
though I have five of them, they're not equally spaced. I can't add two fifhts
and three tenths together because I'm not dealing with the same dimensions or
length. I know one fifth of a kilometer is actually longer than one tenths of a
kilometer, so I can't simply add fifth and tenths together. Remember, I need to
get a common denominator. So, what do you think? What would be the common
denominator for two fifths and three tenths? You can enter your answer in this
box here. Just give me only the denominator. What would you change tenths and
fifths into?